hey guys welcome back to the game spot
stage at e3 2016 I'm Mary your host for
the next couple hours and I'm delighted
to be joined by gamespot reviews editor
Peter Brown hey as well as rich and
megan from Crystal Dynamics thanks for
joining us yeah it's good to be here and
you guys uh you guys have something very
special to share with us this is a not
just you know some clips or some new
assets we're talking about a legacy of
lara croft and tomb raider because it's
her birthday and she is turning 20 years
old this year it's really exciting for
us because we are you know this year
celebrating 20 years of an icon you know
Lara Croft has had such an impact on
culture and on the gaming industry and
on our fans and so it's great to be able
to look back and celebrate all the
moments and you know Megan's going to
share a few details with you on some of
the things that we've uncovered but we
kick things off obviously with you know
the rise of the Tomb Raider launch on PC
in January and then we had Laura's
birthday the official birthday in
February and then in March we partnered
with game changer charity to reveal our
20 years of an icon logo so we're trying
to do something every month to surprise
our fans and to reward them and and
we're basically making sure that we have
something new every single month to
celebrate what we're calling the year of
Tomb Raider yeah there's so much to
celebrate not only you know the legacy
of the tomb raider franchise but Lara
Croft herself as this very interesting
and iconic character that is just so
well known not just in the game world
but I mean she has moved through movies
she's been on magazine covers mean that
girl's been everywhere yeah absolutely
and one of the things that we revealed
at PAX East was bar first really big
drop in so we revealed an official tomb
raider 20 head of our ebook which we
will have the cover reveal at the end of
segment which is that so exciting yeah I
had a big book coming out yeah and I had
the like incredible responsibility and
honor of writing it so it was a lot of
fun it was also an experience that kind
of made me feel like a tomb raider
myself like digging up all these old
assets so that it's been a really cool
experience writing that and we also
revealed the original composer for tomb
raider one through three he's
remastering and reimagining the
soundtrack from the first three games
and he's putting it together in a
compilation called the tomb raider sweet
he's going to take it on tour
with a concert it's gonna be really
really amazing so things like that these
these ways to celebrate different facets
of what tomb raider means to people
we're going to be doing throughout the
entire year absolutely because there's
just so many different ways that you can
view tomb raider or lara croft as this
icon she's gone through a lot of changes
over 20 years as most people do through
their first 20 years you know from the
braid to the outfits to even like her
signature flip when she jumps i mean a
lot of things have changed but it sounds
like you guys actually have some old
assets that you dug through that you are
excited to show us yeah it was really
fun so on social media were basically
every two weeks swapping out a new game
so we started with tomb raider one 1 two
2 meter 3 now but some of the stuff that
we dug out for tomb raider to was really
exciting i think we're going to scroll
through some of those but 1997 and two
marine for 2 meter to it was just a
really really breakout year for the
franchise in terms of transcending
beyond gaming here's one of the original
pieces of tomato to concept art how she
looks barely rugged but that's a very
iconic braid yeah well that looks like a
comic strip I know I love it and so yeah
1997 was a really big year for Tomb
Raider and that's when they first got
the the first bites of interest for
comics mean that's even when they first
started getting people reaching out of
about movie potential is the second year
of the franchise and it didn't really
wasn't seen to fruition until 2001 but
that Animation Studios reaching out
movie studios reaching out trying to to
gauge interest and then eventually they
went forward and started pitching it to
Hollywood but it was it was a big year
in lara transcend gaming she became this
pop-culture icon the thing that I always
love you know Mary you mentioned how
she's changed all over the 20 years but
there's also things that have remained
constant things are just intrinsic to
lara croft you think about her
intelligence you know her drive her will
her bravery you know she has these
things that you just always associate
with or whether it's the classic games
from core whether it's you know the
crystal games like legend and and and
and underworld or the new reboot modern
you know survival action games there's
always these things that you just feel
like they are just part of lara croft
and make her the cultural icon that she
is yeah that's why she's resonated so
much with the fans and and that's
something in particular with the book
that I'm really proud of is we have a
hundred pages I counted it 100 pages
dedicated to our community in this book
and and Laura as this character who has
evolved has appealed to the fandom in so
many unique ways it's funny because
they're all very unique in personal
stories and at the same time they're
also like this universal story of their
connection with lara and so we explore a
lot of those and it's a it's just lovely
to see how everybody's banded together
over her over the last 20 years ya
series like you know to marry you you
look at it and in over the years it's
sort of you can say okay where was
gaming at that point in time and where
was lara and he's gonna be like almost
in lockstep with one another you know
and that i remember the first time i
played the game it was it was on pc when
it just dropped i think i've just got
broadband and that was one of the first
things i was able to download and I was
I was really blown away by the original
game and i'm curious how far like did
you guys get your hands on it back then
when it first came out like what did it
mean to you absolutely yes that's why
i'm aiming I think I mean Laura inspired
me to you know always be brave and bold
and to it was one of the things that
made me wanted to work in gaming because
i was so impressed by its ability to
convey emotion and atmosphere and all
these things and it was sort of the
first time I felt represented in video
games and it's so funny I tell this to
people it's like I really didn't have
much in common with her she's like this
really wealthy British aristocrat with
dual guns and super acrobatic and all
these sorts of things but she was a lady
and she had brown hair and that's all I
needed as a twelve-year-old was to feel
inspired she was super strong and like
it was just a really rad character
smelly software I think you're pretty
acrobatic ice climbing my cosplays is
Lara Croft she's climbing up in ice
glaciers that little I think the time I
spilled coffee in your office means I'm
a little then she did it back to the end
of the table I appreciate that it's yet
it's so much fun though because you know
I've been playing it from the beginning
you know back in 99 6 and for me it
brought together so many things that I'd
never experienced in vb not just Lara
Croft and how you know amazing it was to
have a hero like that on screen right
I'd never seen before in gaming but you
know we walked into a tomb in that sense
of isolation and just
grandeur in the the way that they had
changes how adventure was delivered and
and her attitude and it puts so many
things together the other games maybe
had had touched upon but I'd never
gotten that complete package and that
was that was really the year that I
started to really fall in love with
gaming and I will never forget the first
time I did the swan dive I'll probably
share that with many many millions of
people around the world but first time
you do a swan dive and you're just
you're like okay for the first tier X Y
a moment you're like walking into that
first game interview and like there's
that pool of water and I would always
run for the pool water it's like hide
there because I was afraid of the fair
but I mean you know I'm really guilty of
this I tend to talk a lot about Laura
and Lara's amazing and huge inspiration
so many people the game like you guys
are saying the game was so incredible
and it was so immersive in this
beautiful 3d world that you could
interact with and you could see Laura
and and see how she interacted versus
like the first person games and it was
just such a unique game and that
isolation the willingness to have
moments of quiet and yes with nothing
going on but locking Raiders ironmans
gameplay was also quite innovative I
mean tomb raider to did a lot of firsts
for a lot of games that were 3d which
was like a pretty unsure thing back in
the day back in the 90s that was like
something that they did and I remember
getting the demo on a Playstation and
when you're like in Venice and even like
mmm as little as swimming in sweetie was
really new wall climbing yeah traversal
through vehicles like snowmobile and
things like that those are all gameplay
elements that were just unbelievably fun
didn't matter who I was I was having a
really good time the mixing of action
and puzzles that you get the highs of
being able to shoot bears in cave then
right after that you have to use your
brain and you have to figure out how to
get something or the uniqueness of
exploration of finding secrets you know
it really encouraged people to go into
you know into new areas absolutely and
when you talk about how you know laura
has changed but also kept things that
are intrinsic to her over the 20 years i
think the same thing on the gameplay
side you know obviously with the reboot
you know the modern survival action you
know a grounded you know mature feel to
it's very different for us with what we
were doing now with crystal but rise
litter mayor the main reason why Laura
can
swim in that game is because the fans
wanted that they asked for it and and we
felt like that was the perfect type of
nostalgic thing that we could include as
a way to to pay homage to the to the
previous game or you know things like
the bear or having now the manner in the
cutscenes so you know we I love looking
at it and I love working on it from from
not just a we're steering this huge
incredibly influential franchise but
also as a fan you know I get to see
those things that I loved when I was
playing the original games now coming
back and to rise the tomb Raider's we
see lara you know continuing to progress
toward that tomb raider that we all know
and love you know what i really want to
have bring back is being able to like
mess around in the manner before you
actually go out into the game and the
original games you could always just
like hang out in your mansion and
pretend you were super rich and like get
lost in the maze or do all these like
different flips and stuff of that idea a
lot of people seem to be interested it
was just such an awesome time to enjoy
they had nothing to do with the game but
with fun to do so much a part of her
personality and it sold that
aristocratic element to her you know
just listening to the the classic piano
music and seeing the harp in her
gymnasium a cool and you know and there
were secrets in her house if you're like
investigating enough and so it sounds
like you guys have like a lot of stuff
that you were able to cover and you're
kind of like going into the closet of
all these all these moments of history
from this wonderful series and you had
to shove it into a book a very small how
do you do all in reading it is pretty
incredible III have to say you know I I
cannot I can't even stay the amount of
heart and soul that Megan put into this
there's nobody better to write it but
this is literally not just the most
comprehensive book that I've ever seen
on to murder but of any video game
franchise ever I mean this thing is
absolutely massive the amount of things
that Megan was able to uncover you know
she she can't tutor own horn like this
slow stuff but I think fans of the
franchise young and old of the classic
as well as the modern they're gonna find
something to like because there is so
much in the book that celebrates you
know Lara Croft and celebrates the
gameplay and behind-the-scenes stuff
around the development that you didn't
know and stuff around the movie that I
had no idea about around the comics
around the fans like Megan said with so
much content dedicated to the cosplayers
and the people who do the paper crafts
and like there is so much in this book
it
is it's gonna be a treasure I guarantee
for any fan I hope people enjoy it yeah
I mean it was it was a really incredible
experience writing it and I have to
admit it was a little intimidating
talking to some of my like my heroes
from my youth and getting to chat with a
core design crew and people who rode and
designed and the art for my game the
games that inspired me growing up it was
it was really incredible and set
dressers from the movie and people
sending me photos like physical photos
like do you want a very personal gonna
put them in the book and it was it was
really incredible experience so
hopefully people will enjoy it it's big
so yeah that's something like I have to
give prema a huge thank you for this
because I kept exceeding my word count
and stop saying I do they were like
don't worry just give us what you think
the book should be and it ended up being
350 pages okay yeah they increased the
size quite a bit for me which I
appreciate well I'm sure the fans will
thank them as well so when can people
expect to see this book on shelves or so
later this year yeah okay no uh late
fall time frame is when we're currently
planning to release it but we did have a
little yeah eyes around we have a gutter
finished we are gonna do be the cover
here yeah some exciting it'll much
recovered pretty soon we're a bit of the
design of it but you want to talk about
the design of the 20-year logo and how
we use that on yeah absolutely i think
that one of the things that was really
important to us was making sure that
when we're celebrating 20 years of an
icon that when you look at the logo
you're not thinking oh that's Laura from
this game or oh that's classic Laura
versus you know modern survival action
you know tomb raider lara so it was a
long and involved process but it was it
was a great and collaborative process
you know with with with the team and the
artists there to pull together a
representation of laura that still has
those iconic you know traits that i
mentioned so you instantly look at you
recognize that silhouette is lara croft
but you actually can't tell you know
which version of lara croft is it
because it's actually meant to be all of
them there's things in there that are
shared across both in there things are
unique to each version of lara croft so
we look at that the 20 years of an icon
logo is sort of a celebration and
amalgamation
of how she's changed over the 20 years
so you can't when you look at it you
can't quite tell if she has a braid or a
ponytail you can't quite tell that
little silhouette on the side of her is
a bit of a backpack or is she wearing
pants or shorts and are those dual
holsters or is that the single holster
from the new game Cena so it's it's a
really neat visual play on all of the
different silhouettes of Laura and I
don't think anyone has anyone uncovered
the secret message that's inside the
loader yeah the fans out there they did
it quickly but i'm not doing today I
don't think the general population as so
there's actual secret there is a logo it
is all about discoverability the tomb
raider franchise is about you know
finding what was lost and so in the logo
itself there's actually a few secrets
yeah there's nothing more than a sense
of discovery that kind of reminds me of
the Tomb Raider series that's really
cool that you were able to capture that
in basically like a logo that's just
like it doesn't even have color right
like you've made a silhouette of Laura
to kind of contain it because she's gone
through so many color evolutions as well
right deal tapia there's so many things
that are very iconic color wise to tomb
raider whether it's like the teal of the
top and then since it's evolved so much
yeah keeping the very classic silhouette
was the way to do it and end the red and
the gold the celebratory colors so yeah
okay and and so that's something that we
can't expect to see later this year when
it when that'll probably be something
you guys kind of have more announcements
coming up we will have something every
single month for our fans again this
this year of Tomb Raider is all about
finding ways to celebrate with the fans
letting fans tell us you know we have a
video testimonial site if you go to tomb
raider 20.com it's basically our hub
where you can see all the activity we
have going on you know fan art contests
there's a way that our fans can be
immortalized in a print project that
we're going to reveal later this year so
we just revealed a statue that we're
doing so you can actually go to go to in
like a half hour so we'll have the poll
up but lara croft facebook page and we
have a series of statutes through gaming
heads who are super super talented on it
like gaming statues and it's a six
statue series they're one-fourth size
statues that they all fit very large
they fit and make it together all six of
them so there's three from core design
there's three from Crystal Dynamics
different iconic outfits and
fans can actually vote between if they
want to have the tomb raider chronicles
catsuit lara in the black catsuit or if
they want the tomb raider angel of
darkness and that will be the final
statue so my toe well I think we've done
enough hype let's let's see it lets see
however this is the reveal of the tomb
raider icon well that's see yep
diversity icon there and you can see the
the text that Ridge was talking about a
secret message in there and then there's
the book nice yeah so we wanted to keep
it like classic and simple but it's the
full title 20 years of tomb raider
digging up the past defining the future
and that was sort of a play on the fact
that obviously Lara's job is always
looking to the past but in doing so she
really into me to really define the
future of gaming and even to some degree
entertainment and and the role of female
leads and gaming and pop culture and so
on and so we yes lots of reveals today
and we will continue to have surprises
for our fans every single month so again
it's the year tomb raider so every
single month we will have something well
happy birthday Laura happy birthday tomb
raider and thank you rich and megan for
showing us the brand new cover of the
book thank you alright thank you for
having us oh you're so welcome and thank
you guys for hanging out with us we have
a lot more coming up so don't go
anywhere stick around stay tuned to
gamespot
you're watching the game spot stage
brought to you by airheads